[Music]
morning everyone good morning thanks for
coming hopefully I would enjoy the
keynote we are here to present how
serverless helps you build highly
scalable and secure apps so I'm joined
on stage by Miles Boren's he's a
developer advocate on Google cloud
platform and he is also a member of the
nodejs technical steering committee and
he also triage is all of the the bugs
that come in about node so if you're
finding bugs about node he is the man
determining if they are serious or
otherwise mm-hmm hopefully right right
this is Michael McDonald a product
manager here at Google done work on
firebase and GCP a lot of our recent
security products were things that
Michael was working on or really excited
to talk to you today all about doing
server lists on cloud and how some of
the products that Michael has been
working on and some of our partners have
been working on you know will help you
write secure applications cool so how
many people feel like there are security
experts anyone want to raise your hand
couple yeah I don't even feel this way
so we're gonna actually start kind of
from foundations and talk about what is
a threat environment and go over common
vulnerabilities or common threats that
your app may face so hopefully you'll
walk out of this if you're not feeling
like you're an expert at the end of it
hopefully you'll feel at least a little
more confident we'll also be talking
about you know in the kind of
traditional world what those threats
look like and how they translate into a
service world serverless does a lot of
things automatically but there are still
some things that you're gonna have to do
and lastly we'll also talk about how
Google Cloud and in particular Google
cloud service offerings make a lot of
that easy and in the places that we
don't automatically do for you we have
some partners and other vendors that
will come up on stage and demonstrate
how their tools can help make your apps
more secure as a bit of a high-level
overview a couple things one we have the
camera emoji that means pull out your
phone and take a picture or otherwise
make a mental note of it but the first
important link that we're gonna be
sharing is node sec roadmap so if you go
to this link it has a ton of different
threats a lot of them are kind of
we're kind of in the context of nodejs
but the threats themselves are general
and can apply to whatever language or
environment you're running in so we're
gonna be using node we obviously have
some pretty deep technical expertise
there but it should apply to whatever
language you're working in so we just
use the term threat environment you're
probably wondering what is a threat
environment here's a definition from a
software engineer Mike Samuel he's
actually the engineer who put together
the node SEC roadmap that we just showed
a threat environment is a set of targets
under attack and the tools that might be
used to get at them it's important to
know that different targets are
vulnerable to different tools in
different ways so an application running
on one type of provider is going to be
vulnerable to different types of tools
than an application running in another
environment if you're running an
application in a virtual machine that
you are maintaining yourself on your own
silicon there is a different threat
environment than if you're running
something on App Engine and knowing that
threat environment helps you know what
tools you need to have to protect
yourself from attack so we're gonna talk
about a couple different threats today
quickly listing them off we're going to
talk about zero-days malicious and low
quality code remote code execution
denial of service
classically referred to as a DOS will
talk about leaked credit credentials
we'll talk about data exfiltration query
injection and one of my favorites which
doesn't always make these lists poor
developer experience I'll dig into that
in a bit cool so we decided the best way
of showing common vulnerabilities is to
build a really terrible app and show it
to you so miles went on vacation over
this past weekend and I was hounding him
ceaselessly on Friday afternoon to build
an application for our demo and he of
course just wants to go on vacation so
he actually builds the app on the way
back from Tahoe so you know it's like a
three four hour drive he hacked together
a bunch of functions to build a content
management solution and obviously
written any code written in the back of
a car is bound to be absolutely horrific
right so he has a save markdown function
by the way if no one is familiar with it
we're using cloud functions so cloud
functions is Google cloud platforms
functions as a service offering which is
the prototypical serverless offering and
so he wrote a function that takes in
markdown converts it to HTML and writes
it to cloud sequel and then we have
another function that can serve that
HTML from cloud sequel we're actually
even just gonna focus on that first
function cuz trust me there are a lot of
things wrong with it so this is fun you
might think that we're just making a fun
joke but I legitimately wrote this in
the car on the way home from Tahoe and
before we dive into the code I'm just
going to show you that this is live and
actually works this is the payload that
we're sending it's right in the body
like you know any any good post request
should do the author is my name the
title oh my god the hack stores are at
it again and the markdown drop tables
low we're gonna go and post that and
we're gonna have our response from the
database because you know your raw
database response is what you should
always be returning and we could see
that this works so let's take a look at
the source really quickly
you could see that we're promised fine
stuff because we're using node 8 which
we just announced yesterday which means
we can use a single eight which I
absolutely adore we have all of our
credentials in line so we never have to
look at that piece of paper that I have
on my desk
we immediately create a connection to
the pool we're doing this with creating
a pool for the my sequel direct
connection so that it will be able to
pool resources when we have multiple
functions go up and be able to reconnect
if we have any connection issues this is
also another feature that we just
announced you can do direct connect from
cloud functions now in the make post
async function here we're gonna go we're
gonna convert the markdown that's been
sent to us into HTML we're gonna make a
new date object we're gonna post
directly in you could see all the
information that we're doing in line
here nice and sanitized or not
then we're gonna promise returning it
and we just do a little try-catch here
where we await the results of make post
and then we respond with the results
themselves back to the slide there are
definitely some issues with that yeah so
the first thing that we're gonna talk
about right if we were completely
unaware of these vulnerabilities we
might run into something called
zero day so how many people are familiar
with zero days tell people okay half the
room so normally when you have a threat
you have this thing called the window of
vulnerability so it's kind of from the
time that the vulnerability is disclosed
ideally someone you know sends the email
to security at your company comm and
says hey I think there's an issue
hopefully they're not selling it on the
Internet to someone else who's gonna go
and exploit that but ideally you know in
the in the best case you the vendor get
that information
you tell your engineers or you go and
patch that vulnerability yourself and
ideally you can actually patch the
vulnerability and get users to apply it
before any exploit is actually found or
used but if the exploit is active before
things are fixed you have this kind of
window of vulnerability your kind of
danger zone of when users are likely to
encounter it in a zero-day that's
entirely flipped right the whole premise
of a zero-day is the exploit is actually
active and out in the wild before anyone
knows about it or you know you become
immediately aware on day zero that
there's a problem and then you have to
scramble to go and fix all of your code
and hopefully get users to update it so
how do you stay ahead of what zero days
potentially exists to avoid those so
acronyms we're at a Google conference so
we have lots of acronyms for you see VEC
na cwe so the first one CVE the common
vulnerability and exposures this is
enumerated list that you can get from
mitre every single CVE is a number that
you can go and look up it will give you
the name of it of the dependency or
project that has a vulnerability and
what that vulnerability is with a CVE
number we're able to know what's going
on if you're running a certain project
like node in production for example you
can cross-reference against known CVEs
and know if the version that you're
using is vulnerable or not and what
vulnerabilities you're vulnerable to you
have a CNA which is his CVE numbering
authority this is who assigns a CDE
number to a vulnerability and the node
project for example we actually get pre
assigned blocks of CV use from mitre
directly and act as our own CA
associating CDE numbers with
vulnerabilities as we discover them
before we became a CNA we were actually
using mitre direct
see a so every time a new vulnerability
was about to be disclosed we would write
mitre with that information and then
they would get back to us with a number
this actually resulted in times where we
would have to put the patch up before we
had the number and update with the
number later which is why we went
through the process of becoming a CNA
the third one that we have there cwe a
common weakness enumeration cwe's are a
list of numbers that you can use to
reference certain types of
vulnerabilities and known patterns that
are problematic so if you are a security
researcher you may use a cwe when
reporting so for example using all these
in a sentence an open-source project can
use The MITRE CNA to issue a CVE for a
patch vulnerability when a security
researcher reports a vulnerability they
may include a relevant cwe awesome
thanks miles these links up here go to
CB e + CW e which are both on might org
so you can go through and look at what
CVEs are out there what you have to
worry about and if you're thinking about
reporting things you can go to the CW e
to include a CW e with your report to a
project when you're reporting a
vulnerability so vulnerabilities go all
the way down the stack when we start off
and think about it you have your
hardware I'm not going to talk about
some of those hard rip on durability x'
that happened recently because they
caused me existential dread so we're
going to move up the stack and that
moves to the operating system
these can be vulnerable gulnur abilities
in things like in Linux it could be in
pasta itself we had a really fun one
back in the day with real path 3 and
node find me later I'll tell you about
that one we move up the stack and we
move to our language runtime this is
note itself there may be vulnerabilities
in node such as regular expression
bosses which we've had in the past and
patched fairly recently you move up the
stack and you're now into your
dependencies everything that you've
installed via NPM we've seen some
recently and we'll dig into you know
vulnerabilities that could affect you
via your dependencies and finally you
reach the top of your stack you reach
your application and it's possible that
you're writing your own vulnerabilities
the thing that's important to see about
this all the way down is like well you
need to be
managing your own application code and
making sure that your team is writing
secure code there is a lot of stuff
underneath you that can be causing you
to be vulnerable in a transparent way
you may have no idea now a great thing
about running serverless
is that everything below your
dependencies is managed by us so if you
to play something to cloud functions or
you deploy something to App Engine
standard whenever we get notified of new
CVEs
whenever new patches are available we're
able to patch the language runtime the
operating system and even replace the
hardware from under you without any
downtime or you having to make any
changes on your end when the node
project does a new security release we
are in a timely manner updating all of
the functions that are already deployed
so the next time that it runs is not
going to be vulnerable this is one of
the advantages to using server lists so
one of the things that we talked about
are the dependencies which is bringing
in malicious or low-quality code into
your project so there's lots of ways
that this can get in you can have
malicious code this is code that is
explicitly trying to be malicious and do
things like pulling things from pastebin
you can have low quality to dependencies
these are just packages that weren't
very well designed and introduced
unexpected bugs and performance problems
into your code regular expression bosses
are some of the most active ones that
you'll find here and also unintended
requires it's possible that you
unintentionally require things into your
project because of dynamic dependencies
so one of the things that that bad
dependencies may do or even your happen
in your own code is remote code
execution how many people in the
audience are shipping a Val in
production or the equivalent in your
language and you may actually be
shipping a val and not even realizing it
if you're using VM run in this context
or any of the VM objects in node that
actually is still sharing the same
context and you may be leaking and
changing your context if you're running
and unsanitized or unknown code so
remote code execution
an example of this actually happened
fairly recently with the es lint
security incident is anyone familiar
with it so last week
yes lint scope module was hijacked to
steal and PMRC credentials one of the
maintainer x' of the es lint project had
their machine compromised the person who
compromised the machine then published a
new version of the es lint scope module
as a patch update
yes landscape module is dependent by yes
lint and if any of you write JavaScript
yes Lynch is the most widely used tool
for linting code which is the way that
we know that we write errors because
dynamic languages are fun so when this
vulnerability happened the credentials
were stolen malicious code was published
that malicious code was pulling down a
pastebin link and then executing it via
eval and at that point it was then
uploading credentials or attempting to
upload credentials to a centralized
service this is what's formerly known as
worm it was compromised and then trying
to compromise other packages and spread
across the ecosystem there's a couple of
different ways that we could defend
against this if you were using explicit
lock files you wouldn't have updated to
the patch version if you were sticking
to the lock file and if you had had two
factor authentication turned on on your
account the worm would not be able to
spread because when it tried to publish
it would be asking for your credentials
I think this is a really great example
of where the inconvenience of 2fa pays
off in the not having all of your
modules stolen so this was how the
attacker did it they modified the
package.json in both Islan scope and
insulin config adding a post install
script that ran that ran this lib build
Jas and Lib build yes called an HTTP GET
on paste bin got the information and
then eval dit this right here that line
is why the worm did not spread as wide
as it could generally in node when
you're doing something Don you want to
be concatenated the entire string and
then do on end to evaluate it what we
can tell from this attack though is that
we had a really sophisticated attacker
who just was not well versed in the node
api's so thankfully this caused a whole
bunch of crashes to happen and then
those crashes when it tried to eval C&C
wasn't a full string
it was how people noticed it within ten
minutes and you know this is I think one
of the really great examples of how on
top of it the node community is because
the second that people knew about it
everyone knew about it and you know
things were getting locked down and to
come talk about a little bit more about
this and some ways of protecting your
projects we have CJ Saverio the CTO of
NPM quick round of applause I see each
how you doing today pretty good you told
me it was a story about a week that I
had was not so good but it's good
thankfully we talked about it before
yeah so CJ's gonna come up and and demo
something
CJ's in our insecure project that we
were just showing you where I brought in
a whole bunch of dependencies really
quickly and see what are you gonna do
for us today I'm gonna show you how we
help you close that gap between when a
vulnerability is found it's been patched
but you're still not in the green zone
because you don't know about it and you
haven't applied that patch to your
project so I'm going to demonstrate a
really pretty nifty new thing that we've
done at MPM to allow you to find out how
to do something about this without
interrupting your normal workflow here
I'm in miles is in secure project and
I'm just gonna run npm install like I
always do maybe I'm installing a new
dependency maybe I'm just running
installed a new development a ho holy
high-severity Batman I have a high
severity vulnerability that I didn't
know about so now I can find out more
information about that if I want and
notice I didn't do anything special to
find out now I'm gonna run a new command
for NPM called NPM audit here I find
that marked the library I've been using
to render my markdown for my app has a
regular expression denial of service
okay okay what does that mean all right
I'm probably vulnerable to it what
should I do to fix it well that's easy
too NPM audit fix the great thing here
is if we can give you a patched version
of that dependency without violating
your cember requirements that are in
your package JSON we
we'll do it and we will give you the fix
right here with you having to do
anything more than just that fixed one
vulnerability now if I run npm install
clean i'm i'm in that green zone now I'm
safe I've patched that's really awesome
and it was it yeah and can you tell me a
little bit more about how it knew that
there was a vulnerability we have taken
the node Security Project vulnerability
database which is the collective work of
the node ecosystem which takes this very
seriously and we've integrated that in
with NPM install so every time you do a
read of packages we have that security
data passed down even if you even if
you're pulling from your local cache we
can tell you that that we found
something that you didn't know about
last time you ran an install that's
really amazing and then we were just
talking before about two-factor
authentication
I believe NPM has some new stuff coming
yes we do the es lint maintainer x' who
also had a very bad week could have done
a couple of things to make to protect
themselves from it they could have
turned on two-factor off for all rights
so that anytime they pub they typed
publish for any package they own they
would have to provide a one-time
password we've just rolled out last week
in response to this a brand-new feature
where you can protect a package with
two-factor off so at any time any
maintainer publishes it whether they've
turned on to FA or not they have to
enable it provide a one-time password
and install it isn't inconvenience but
if you publish to NPM please protect
your packages if you are using a very
highly popular package enable this and
this is in the MPM CLI or at our website
you just flip it on wonderful thank you
so much huge welcome
[Applause]
cool
so we saw right there regular fresh and
denial-of-service how do people feel
like they know what denial of services
are a couple of them Mike my god stop
Mike up Mike won't have time for this
okay
there you go so miles just exhibited a
very classic example of a denial of
service right you have traffic coming in
to your application and malicious
traffic then starts bothering you maybe
it's you know taking up network
resources or you know your CPU just hits
100% you can't do anything anymore you
can't focus on that task that you were
supposed to do earlier but there are
also a number of other kinds of denials
of service right so the resource
exhaustion case that we showed there of
say running out of network or running
out of CPU but you also have a couple of
other categories of things that could
cause denials of service the regular
expression das for instance could be
kind of a code error issue where maybe a
well-formed request comes in but it
triggers some bug in the code that you
know ends up creating a resource
exhaustion or maybe there's other
expensive computation so for instance we
were doing crypto on the main thread in
node and basically dossed ourselves and
then my personal favorite denial of
service is an economic denial of service
right where someone you know one of the
great things about server list is that
it scales infinitely you keep throwing
traffic at it and it keeps scaling which
potentially means that it keeps billing
you right so if you have budget said or
there are quotas in place those could be
throttling you so we thought we showed
the kind of classic denial of service of
a resource exhaustion will now show a
really fun one the hug of death of
dossing yourself so you may have
external traffic coming in and as your
cloud functions are scaling up maybe
they're writing to that sequel database
you run out of file descriptors or you
know there are some other finite
resources and you overload your database
and it falls over so we have a really
cool new tool so scaling controls so
again it's really great to have you know
the infinite scalability of functions of
the service but sometimes because not
everything is serverless
and amazing under the hood you want to
say limit to only a hundred functions
can run because you may only have you
know hundred file descriptors or
whatever there's some some limiting
resource in the backend you can deploy
your functions with the max instances
flag and limit it so once you've done
that your functions will start scaling
up and they'll hit that max instances
limit and Peter off so traffic you'll
you'll start providing back pressure up
to your clients
maybe the clients will force retries or
do something like that but your database
will be fine a quick note so we have a
couple of different service products
within Google Cloud functions is kind of
the the main common one but we also have
App Engine so App Engine you're running
an application rather than just a single
function it has a slightly different
scaling behavior so as your App Engine
app is scaling up it'll hit that max
instances limit but then it will also
start routing traffic back to existing
apps because they can continue serving
that traffic so it will still provide
that scaling limit but the behavior will
be slightly different so just something
to take into account if you're building
an app on App Engine versus functions
and then to prevent the kind of economic
denial of service we can do budget
alerts so you can actually go into your
project and say I want to be notified
anytime I hit fifty percent 90 percent a
hundred percent whatever percent you
want of your budget and my favorite
feature of this is that you can actually
then trigger cloud functions off of your
budget alert so you know if you get a
budget alert saying that your cloud
functions have exceeded 100 percent you
can trigger more cloud functions just a
fun little thing but that is nice
because then you could say trigger a
cloud function that would kill an
offending process or otherwise shut down
resources or deny access it's a nice
little way of containing that so a great
way to cause problems for yourself is
leaking credentials if any of you were
paying attention earlier you may have
noticed that I leaked all of our
database can I put credentials on screen
to all of you now we're going to be
shutting that database down later but if
you had been paying attention you
probably could have made some problems
from my demo but there are common
credentials and common ways that you
could leak it
database user and password as we saw is
a really easy way to leak it leaking it
by writing it right into your code
that's a great way to say that you
accidentally put it into your get repo
you push it to get up there's bots that
are constantly doing static analysis of
github to find these kinds of leak
credentials you can potentially leak
ooofff credentials this could happen by
potentially sending credentials in a
request not over HTTP
anything that's in any of those hops if
your credentials are in plain text
they're they know not only your
credentials but where you were sending
them to you could have a credential leak
through improper use of crypto and you
could also as I was mentioning publisher
credentials accidentally just somewhere
like github er NPM now here's an example
of putting the credentials right into
your code one of the things that you'll
notice about this that is particularly
problematic is this my sequel doc create
pool call this is a pretty generic way
of making this call this is very
statically analyzable BOTS can crawl
text we have bigquery bigquery lets you
do this like you can write parsers that
will go through and just find this and
leak the credentials for you so one way
that we've been thinking about fixing
this and worked on fixing this is a
great new feature called environment
variables something I'm really excited
about you can now in the deployment set
environment variables for your cloud
functions you can also set them in the
UI when you deploy it by setting these
environment variables we then inside of
our code could reference the environment
variables rather than referencing the
items themselves and now there's
absolutely no way that we're going to be
leaking these credentials using our code
now this is not foolproof and we'll dig
into that in a minute
but this is a huge step forward now if
you didn't want to put it into the
environment variables there's other ways
that you could be storing your
credentials we have cloud KMS which is
cloud hosted keys you could use the hash
of court bolt we'll be showing some
other ways to do it so you don't need to
put it onto your prop right into the
process into your environment variables
but it is you know a really great step
that you can take without a lot of
engineering investment to make your code
more secure right off the bat I'm really
glad we didn't see anyone like get up
and run out of the room and
okay so we talked a lot about
credentials but there are also a number
of things in the kind of authentication
realm of what you're doing with those
credentials or how you're checking those
credentials they can be potentially
problematic especially in a surveillance
world so when we started miles had a
single function the Save markdown
function that went ahead and took the
markdown or HTML wrote to the database
we decided you know good code practices
we wanted to split those into write we
wanted to have a generic markdown to
HTML function because maybe we want to
send our markdown or our HTML somewhere
else and then we also wanted to restrict
you know all that horrific write to the
database
you know passwords and secrets in code
into its own little separate function so
at the end you know everyone in the
end-user world is not directly having
access to our database that was awesome
except for the fact that all of these
functions are public on the internet so
someone could simply bypass all of our
restrictions set up in our Mike down to
HTML function and write malicious HTML
directly into our database
it's called execution flow manipulation
and it's you know as we move into a
world of micro services or nano services
I'm trying to make that catch on by the
way nano services as we move into that
world
these attacks become much more common
especially when you have events you know
you could imagine an event being
triggered from a Google Cloud Storage
bucket going to a function writing to a
database trigger another event there are
a lot of little attack vectors kind of
between those cracks so one of the new
features that we're announcing is
security controls between functions so
you can set an iamb policy on a function
that lets you control access from not
only developers but other functions or
other GCP services you could have you
know GCE VM or an app engine app
securely writing to your function as
well as end users who've signed in via
Google sign-in one of the other things
that we're doing is we're starting to
make functions private by default so
your functions your HTTP functions will
no longer be publicly available on the
Internet the second you to play them
your developers can still you know use
the command line to call them but you
don't have to release everything
publicly immediately so we're gonna add
I am policies on to both of our
functions the first one we're gonna say
all users can take this special invoker
role to invoke our
first function or markdown to HTML
function and on the second one we're
actually gonna say you know we've given
a service account to our second function
and we're gonna say only our first
service account and on our first
function can invoke the second function
otherwise it's closed off from the world
so we have that kind of I am security
barrier between our functions and that
would prevent our malicious content from
coming in to the second function but as
I mentioned earlier we're still making
it easier for developers to use it so if
you're logged in to the command line you
can deploy your function its deployed
privately but you can then just say
g-cloud functions call and call the
function as you normally would and that
will take your developer credentials
pass them through and let you invoke
that function so if you want to sign up
for this it's in alpha right now so you
can take a photo of that sign up and you
can start using it shortly give everyone
a second to to take a look at that okay
perfect
so there's kind of a parallel to that of
not only you know is there a potential
for malicious content to come in but
there's a really high potential for the
good content that you have to leave your
application so you can imagine for
instance instead of a malicious call
coming in to your function you can
imagine that someone has maybe you know
done a remote code execution
vulnerability in one of your functions
and is trying to exfil exfiltrate data
so they're gonna take all that markdown
content and send it to their own
endpoint so you know the evil.com
example down there below or you can
imagine a similar thing where someone
has you know dumped the process
environment variables which you know and
this is why we were saying it's maybe
not the best idea to store all of your
secrets in environment variables if
someone could eval you know console.log
process and and say store that as their
name in the database they could then use
our second function to pull all that
HTML content out of the database kind of
without you knowing we're gonna actually
have one of our partners come up and
talk about how to mitigate those threats
shortly
so joked about this earlier but query
injection is real and alive so the code
that I originally wrote was pretty
susceptible here's a slightly simplified
version of it well you can see that
we're doing that's not so great is we're
building the query manually from a
string and concatenated information
unsanitized that was hand oh and it over
from the internet and one of the things
that could happen here which would be
kind of bad is you know someone who
knows how we have it done internally or
is guessing could hand us off HTML that
internist internally is actually
breaking up the string and including an
extra sequel call that is in turn
deleting all of our information that's
no good we don't want that no good so we
can fix this by escaping and so one of
the things that's really great is my
sequel itself the module for NPM comes
with an escape function this is not the
same as just calling escape on the
string in JavaScript it comes with a
scape function that's going to properly
escape your data to be put up into my
sequel so you can still build the string
without worrying about doing it now well
this is better there is best so we could
avoid sanitizing altogether and rely on
the library to sanitize it for us you'll
see the set question mark syntax that
we're using here this is taken directly
from the my sequel readme as the
preferred way of posting information and
what you could see that we're doing is
we're building an object in JavaScript
we're passing that object over to my
sequel library and we're allowing my
sequel to know how to actually convert
everything itself one of the things
that's really nice about this too is not
only is it going to escape but it's
going to smartly escape so in the
example that I had originally I was
taking a time stamp with a JavaScript
data object you can actually just pass
that directly this way and it will
sanitize and turn the data object into
the string format that my sequel is
expecting so know not only are you're
removing potential programming errors
from a security standpoint you're
removing programming errors from just
straight-up like consistency and correct
way of programming so well the other way
of doing it yourself works like anything
in security if there's a way for you to
not do it
do it let other people who have who have
done it right and made the mistakes
before you do it instead and with that
we're gonna bring up Devin Rifkin from
intrinsic big round of applause so Devin
can you tell us a little bit about
intrinsic sure so intrinsic is a runtime
enforcement system where basically we
want to make it really easy for you to
choose exactly which resources your
Google Cloud functions can access and so
when we talk about how to get really
good security you want to talk about
lease privilege which is the idea that
your function should only be able to do
exactly what it needs to do and nothing
more and this is how we're gonna protect
against some of the issues that Mike was
talking about earlier so the way that
intrinsic works is we actually sit
between the runtime and all of your code
so you've got both application code and
dependency code but what we let you do
is we let you put policies on that so
that you know when you try to go to evil
calm it doesn't work so now we're going
to actually look at some improved code
it's sort of what we've been showing
before so this has some of the fixes
this is the split out one so this is the
first function and this one takes
markdown and it turns it into HTML and
then it passes it to the second function
so when we think about like what
privileges does this function need to do
it's not really very much at all in fact
the only thing it really does is down
here it just posts to this post URL
which is just the second function so
when we think about like how we want to
restrict this function we really want it
so that the only thing it can possibly
do is talk to the second function so
let's look at how we do that with
intrinsic with intrinsic you don't
change your code at all so you keep it
the same and the policies they apply it
to all the code even malicious code
can't get around the policies so we've
got just a single policy here where what
we do is we say hey we want to allow
posting to this particular URL which
corresponds to our second function so
let's go ahead and look at what some
malicious code might look like so
this is a little bit of a contrived
example we're just putting in something
that changes the URL into evil comm but
any of the dependencies could do that or
if you had a remote code execution
vulnerability they could easily you know
exfiltrate the data so let's actually
run this function so we're gonna do a
malicious call and this just uses the
g-cloud functions call and now what's
what's funny here is it says error but
that's actually good that's a good
indication that we're protected but
let's take a look at the logs to make
sure that that's true so here are the
logs and let me make this a little bit
bigger so we see that we tried to post
to evil comm and intrinsic blocked this
so it said hey this is a policy
violation you tried to post the evil
comm and that's not in the whitelist so
all the intrinsic policies because we
really want to focus on the principle of
least privilege there's it's just all
waitlist based you don't want to say
things you can't do you only want to say
there things you can do and this fits in
super well with how serverless works
where you have lots of nano what are we
saying
nano services right so this is great and
this this protects you and you can set
up notifications alerts and stackdriver
to notify your team that something bad
has happened right something totally
unexpected but in the meantime your data
is completely safe so that's very good
we're gonna look at the next function
now so this is the second one and this
one's pretty interesting because we have
another piece of sensitive data which is
the database password that miles leaked
several times already so we've got these
environment variables set up which is
pretty good right that's pretty good
so let's let's go ahead and run this and
we're gonna log the environment
variables so we'll run this right here
okay so it inserted it with an ID 90 I
got rid of my loza's past the database
the results straight through you don't
want to do that so let's take a look at
the logs yeah so kind of as expected my
passwords just there
and so while this is a lot better than
storing it in your code because that
means it shows up in fewer places it
still could be accelerated now luckily
we're using intrinsic so you can't just
post it to another to like your own
attackers server but we might kind of
alluded to this before there is if the
attacker is super clever and they're
trying to really target you
they might just store it in the database
and then go to your blog and see the
password and then mess with it that way
so they might exfiltrate it another way
so we've been working on ways of
preventing you know like like even
leaking it in special ways and what
we've realized is you don't actually
need to see the real value in your code
all you're doing is you're passing along
the password to the my sequel database
you're not operating on the actual value
so this is a new type of policy that
we've introduced called tokenization and
what it does is it takes your real
secrets so your database passwords or
API keys or other sensitive user data
you can imagine social security numbers
you don't really need to do math on them
it turns them into dummy tokens when
it's running in the untrusted code area
which is where all your code runs and
that means both your code and
third-party code never see the actual
value then on the way out we check to
make sure that you're connecting to the
thing that we expect you are and if you
are we'll translate it to the real value
but your code never ever sees the real
secret and that means it's impossible
for that code to leak it so let's see
what that policy might look like so it's
super easy again we don't change any of
our code and we've got a single
tokenization policy here where we say
hey we've got this environment variable
called DB password we want to tokenize
it and then we want to tokenize it we
want to dieto kanai's it only when it
goes to my sequel and only when it
matches exactly this user database and
socket path we don't want somebody to
try to steal it by faking making another
my sequel server and then again you
don't change any code we've got a single
process a single policy we don't need to
make any HTTP calls so let's go ahead
and run this so we run this and it's
looking pretty good we do
of ID 91 so we're inserting more things
let's take a look at the logs and this
is great so instead of the real password
it shows tokenized by intrinsic so if an
attacker wants to steal that fake
password let them do it it's fine and
most importantly it still was able to
post to the my sequel database and
insert it so it worked transparently but
kept you safe and so we're really
excited about these tokenization
policies because they let you just get
rid of whole classes of attacks and it's
really flexible it's not just
environment variables in my sequel
databases the sources might be HTTP
responses where the file system or
database entries and I might go to
database entries where you want to store
things that you never were able to see
and you might D tokenize to particular
HTTP requests if you're using like API
keys and even responses to users so
let's say that you pull a social
security number from the database your
app code never needs to see it if it's
just displaying it to the user so we're
really excited to have people start
using these policies we think it's going
to really help protect things and thanks
that's that's what I got thank you so
much Evan
that was really great so we've kind of
gone through a whole class of errors
that are you know mostly solved through
programming and engineering but
engineering is not just about code if
you are running a team if you are
thinking about the process of your
organization there's a whole class of
vulnerabilities that can come in because
developers just don't have time to deal
with all of your policies if all of your
different security policies that you
have in place make for bad developer
experiences your developers may end up
working around that and making things
even more vulnerable than you started
with so some examples of poor developer
experience include certain kinds of
shared environments having dev staging
and prod all use the same database means
that all of your different environments
have the same restrictions when writing
to the database which may mean that you
have to jump through certain hoops it
can say you know
or don't ya and you can end up with
unreviewed code into production so one
thing that you can do is enforce
isolation and use a deployment manager
to replicate environments to make sure
that you're not getting the wrong things
in the wrong place for doing things you
don't want one of the biggest problems
that can happen for people is a slower
manual tool chain having to manually
deploy everything having it be really
slow introduces lots of errors and edge
cases using things like continued into
continuous integration and continuous
deployment can really help fix that
there's a really awesome tool called
spinnaker which runs on top of
kubernetes that helps you run all this
stuff we also have cloud builder as one
of our products that you can use for
automating the process of docker if you
go and look at the notes a crud map some
of the stuff in there that I
particularly enjoyed with some of the
thoughts and how to separate
environments and creating different
levels of policy for different
environments so for example your
developers can maybe use any module that
they want to use well they're in dev and
when they move to staging your security
team can start auditing them and then
actually send it back to dev if some of
those don't meet the level of quality
that's needed to reach production what
this does is kind of flips it instead of
creating this really strict policy
saying hey you can't use anything right
now it allows your devs to run really
fast get the things that they need to do
done to figure out how to solve the
problem and then once they figured out
those abstractions like on node there's
so many different modules available at
NPM so if we used marked for example and
that dos wasn't fixed yet and they're
like oh no you need another markdown
parser there's seven other markdown
parsers our security team can even come
up with three or four examples that we
could switch to but that doesn't stop
the velocity of your team and so instead
of creating problems we're creating work
it's not hey you can't do this it's like
hey here's another ticket by changing
that story a little bit we changed the
way the developers are working and we
stopped instead of breaking velocity we
improve velocity this moves all the way
through your through your whole process
down to how you're handling to a thing
you need to make sure that the process
that you have in place has buy-in from
your teams and is not hurting velocity
but that doesn't mean that you
promis-- and this is a balance that's
hard to find but what we're hoping is
with all the different things that we
remove by moving you to server lists
that you're able to focus on more laser
focused policies more laser focused
workflows and can create a velocity that
your teams on board with and you in the
end up with much more secure apps at the
end
[Music]